金ちゃん初めてそうですという意味で私今ですね東京の渋谷のとある所に来ております
遠いけどなってここに来たかと言いますとちょっと緊急時台でして見てる皆さんもご
存じだと思うんですけども僕の今の髪型はこんな感じになってるんですよ
させにヤバイさすがにやばいですねかもうこれはこれでていくのでこれなんですよ
なんかこれはこれで面白いんですけどもさすでにね変すぎるなと思いまして本当に
ちょっともう自分で切るの強い子なんかせっかくの機会なんで僕も前で手前が入っ
パーンってなった時にベチャクチャかっこいい歓迎してくださった描写が
いうです今日はその病室にもう一度来ておりますでは突撃していきましょう
続けしまーす
うさ白いです皆さんです宜しくお願いしますお願いします
みなさん僕の産みました見直しました若い女ました
[音楽]
助けてくれ助け次から取材放送力はどうかわかんないけどなるべく
頑張りますありがとうございますあの以前も前髪罰の時にめちゃくちゃいい感じに知っ
ていただけたんですごいすごい
いましたねこれ年かかり目のポイント今ちょっと
頑張り中を引きって丸べくはいそれはいるようにやばいですねそうなんですよ本当お
任せで
緑園応急処置をしていただけるとありましたので助かります
よろしくお願いますかも久々名モルさん
したいあそこにとってなれる
見てもいいですかお願いします
[音楽]
はすごい
2センチとかしかないもんねここ坊主なんて野暮
てくれ
[音楽]
切りますはい早いはシャンプーしますはい
これやばいんですよ
ライゼで実践
1飾ってるの
毎度それな移動
ゆったんてくださいん
いただきましたん
[音楽]
これはこっち寄せるとめっちゃハゲてる人じゃない
ああ
[音楽]
ん
bg
あると思います消防士によっていけばセットしたらだけどもう大丈夫と言うね
[音楽]
安全とかなって
白糸あっあっあっ
ございます
えってほしくないところが切られたあっはぁ
[音楽]
はいそういうわけで無事カットカラー
窃盗美鈴さんにスピードございます
それぞれ枚あります
というわけで早速
本人に銅像してもらいましょう
歩いぞ
[拍手]
あれございますよ
見えるかねすごいつよもう
[音楽]
me
完全にすごいいいなぁ
ここだけ取った曲だよねこれここ少ないですけどでもないけど坊主だがなくなりました
ねあの作っちゃうんだ
いや凄いぜ
全然抹茶受けるぞこれ前歯さっきのひどすぎて分かってね
伊豆道で混獲ポイントは今回のポイントは以下に来られたよ
めだかないするがこの上げることによって
後も発射ですごまかします m 自分が福鈴と思っていけそうです
1か月半で大丈夫か
ここだけ見るとほぼ坊主なんですけども
違うことでない感じに待たせていただきました
本当にありがとうまで別扱いましたもうこれで街を歩けるん
me
あっはぁ